>> Tucker: ONE OF THE MOST
REMARKABLE AND TROUBLING MOMENTS
IN THE YEARS LONG RUSSIA TSONGA
OCCURRED WHEN THE FORMER DEPUTY
FBI DIRECTOR ANDY McCABE CLAIMED
THAT ROD ROSENSTEIN OFFERED TO W
THAT ROD ROSENSTEIN OFFERED TO A
THAT ROD ROSENSTEIN OFFERED TO R
THAT ROD ROSENSTEIN OFFERED TO W
THAT ROD ROSENSTEIN OFFERED TO O
THAT ROD ROSENSTEIN OFFERED TO S
THAT ROD ROSENSTEIN OFFERED TO Y
THAT ROD ROSENSTEIN OFFERED TO H
THAT ROD ROSENSTEIN OFFERED TO E
PRESIDENT.
NOW AT THE TIME ROSENSTEIN
DENIED IT BUT TODAY JUDICIAL
WATCH ANNOUNCED A TWO-PAGE MEMO
FROM MAY OF 2017 IN WHICH
McCABE RECORDS ROSENSTEIN
MAKING THAT OFFER.
IT'S ACCORDING TO THE MEMO,
ROSENSTEIN THOUGHT HE COULD
SNEAK A Y OR N BECAUSE HE WAS
NOT SEARCHED WHEN VISITING THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE THIS REPORT?
>> LAW, THE MEMO AND IN AND OF
ITSELF IS EXTRAORDINARY BECAUSE
IT CAPTURES A MOMENT IN TIME
BETWEEN THE FIRING OF JIM COMEY
AND THE APPOINTMENT OF THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL AND IT
REALLY TO SOME EXTENT LAYS OUT
THE ENTIRE CONVERSATION THAT
ANDY McCABE AS ACTING DEPUTY
FBI DIRECTOR HAD WITH DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROSENSTEIN AND
OTHERS AND I JUST THINK IT'S
EXTRAORDINARY THAT THEY WERE
HAVING A DISCUSSION, WHETHER OR
NOT IT WAS A JOKE, AS I'VE HEARD
ROSENSTEIN ALLEGE, OF WEARING A
WIRE INTO THE WHITE HOUSE IN THE
OVAL OFFICE AND RECORDING THE
PRESIDENT.
IT I CAN IMAGINE UNDER WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCE DOES CONVERSATION
WOULD'VE COME OUT AND WOULD HAVE
BEEN HAVE BETWEEN THOSE
TWO PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: SO I MEAN YOU WERE
TO AT THIS LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT
FOR A LONG TIME.
ASSESS THE LIKELIHOOD THAT IT
WAS A JOKE.
>> AT THE TIME, I WAS THE CHIEF
OF STAFF WHEN ROSENSTEIN ISSUED
THAT EXTRAORDINARY STATEMENT AND
THEN ANOTHER STATEMENT ON TOP OF
THAT IN THE FIRST ONE WASN'T
RECEIVED WELL AND THAT THE STORY
WAS COVERED BY MANY AND IT WAS
OBVIOUSLY THE ONLY EXPLANATION
THAT HE COULD HAVE STAYED IN
THAT ROLE IF IT HAD BEEN A
SERIOUS CONSIDERATION OF WEARING
A WIRE INTO THE OVAL OFFICE AND
OBVIOUSLY THE PRESIDENT COULDN'T
HAVE THE TRUST AND CONFIDENCE SO
HE HAD TO EXPLAIN IT AS BEING A
JOKE AND SAYING THAT AS A
FACETIOUS MATTER.
I DON'T KNOW --
I THINK THERE WERE OTHERS IN
THAT SAME MEETING THAT ALSO TOOK
COPIOUS NOTES.
I WOULD EXPECT THAT SINCE THEY
DO SUCH A GOOD JOB WE WILL SEE
THOSE CONTEMPORARY NOTES AS WELL
BECAUSE I THINK WE ARE FAR FROM
OVER BUT THE PROSECUTOR IN ME
WANTS TO CORROBORATE THE STORY
AND ANY McCABE AT THE TIME HAD
A LOT OF REASONS TO WRITE DOWN
HIS HISTORICALLY INACCURATE
ACCOUNTS BECAUSE HE HAD JUST PUT
THE PRESIDENT INTO THIS
INVESTIGATION IS THE TARGET.
>> Tucker: SO I GUESS THE
OBVIOUS QUESTION IS, DO YOU
THINK, AND YOU KNOW HIM,
ROD ROSENSTEIN, IS CAPABLE OF
THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, I WORKED
SIDE-BY-SIDE WITH ROD AS DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHEN I WAS
ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL AND I
ALSO WORKED WITH HIM WHEN I WAS
CHIEF OF STAFF.
I WOULD BE SURPRISED IF HE HAD
HONESTLY SAID THAT HE WOULD WEAR
A WIRE BUT AT THE SAME TIME IF
YOU READ THE MEMO, IT'S VERY
CLEAR THAT ANDY McCABE DIDN'T
THINK ROD WAS JOKING AND I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE WHAT OTHERS IN THE
ROOM THOUGHT BECAUSE I WAS NOT
IN THE ROOM AT THE TIME AND I
THINK IT WOULD BE A --
IT IS SOMETHING I THINK THAT IS
JUST SO EXTRAORDINARY THAT IT
NEEDS TO BE TALKED ABOUT WHETHER
YOU ARE JOKING OR NOT THAT I
THINK WE NEED A FEW MORE
WITNESSES TO THAT CONVERSATION